this is a pepper panic saga
level 76 walkthrough video
we had a request for this on our
pepper panic tips facebook page and so
i'm gonna play the level through i'm
gonna explain my decisions as we go
and i'm going to suggest that you visit
our site pepper panic tips and read the
pepper panic saga level 76 full guide
first
so that you'll understand the strategy a
little bit better
i
i've made one of these earlier and it
the time went really long so i'm going
to try to
do it as quickly as possible
but i'll try to do my best to explain
everything as as i go
we have to clear the ice that's the most
important thing and
we can see we have four green in the ice
so that would be the best color to go
with
i'm gonna go ahead and make this this
four pepper match at the top even though
it's in a bad spot
because we also have a blue orange there
as well so
all right now i'm going to just match
the green
i think i'm matching from the top
instead because there's a chance that
more will drop in that way
all right we set up a four pepper
vertical match and that'll clear this
ice right here
plus it'll grow the red peppers it's
gonna remove this green one but that's
not a big deal
and we got a nice
drop there that's that's an example of
why clearing out space is so important
and why getting rid of this ice is so
important because that can't happen if
if
we're only working in a really small
area
now even though the red aren't
directly next to any statue i mean
aren't trapped in the ice there are some
that are directly next to statues so
we'll go ahead and make these matches in
order first
because you know we might be able to get
some hits that way and
they cleared out quite a bit of space so
i think those are pretty effective
okay we set up this um i wish i could
say i did that on purpose but i didn't
but we'll take it
now this situation with the four pepper
match isn't really as good
this isn't trapped in the ice anymore
and these shock waves aren't going to
hit
anything
but at the same time there's really no
better move so we'll go ahead and do
that
now things are pretty jumbled up at the
top so i'm going to go ahead and
make this purple
match i'm going to do it vertically
because that'll bring at least a little
shift in the peppers
i don't want to make this red match here
because it'll explode away from the
statues and also just chain reaction
with this one that's away from the
statues
so i'm going to look for something else
instead
i'm going to match the green
it's going to drop the purple to match
with the purple at the same time so that
that's affected the clear space
plus we still have to clear this green
ice if we can
uh these none of the no real great
choices here
it may be time to just go ahead and
and clear this i'm going to make the
blue yet and blue match and yellow match
at the same time and see what happens
but
we might be um
we might be better off at this point
just
clearing out this space
i'd really like to
grow some green but it's just not
possible at the moment
all right so that's not a bad result um
set up a match here where we can get a
hit on the statue
now we got a four pepper match we always
want to look for these because they're
gonna send shockwaves and grow peppers
this is primarily to get rid of this
piece of ice
but it's also nice because it's you know
it creates action and other stuff
happens
and in a sense that gives us free moves
to
you know as those things are happening
we don't lose any moves
uh i'm gonna explode this purple because
it'll
drop some things down
okay i'm gonna go with the green
i'm gonna go ahead and explode this
yellow because that'll set up this green
one
it'll clear the ice and hit these
statues so that's that's a great move
and now things change pretty
considerably because there's nothing in
the way from the top to the bottom
um there's no
immediate four pepper or
lrt shape matches the damage the statue
so what i'm going to do is explode this
one
that's going to hit the statue and then
it's also going to change
cause a chain reaction and this one's
going to explode and hit three statues
and we got a little extra one there so
that's nice
so now we're down to 13 moves and we
really have to be careful to make the
best choices at this point because we
got a lot of statues left
still no shockwave matches available
i am going to i'm going to match the
green the green are set up pretty good
next to
statues so it won't be bad to grow those
but as you can see
you can't really focus on those colors
because things move around
so
after each choice you know you really
want to look things over again to see if
it's still good to go that direction i'm
going to go ahead and do that but
it's not it that's not really ideal
anymore
now
now it's it's a little bit better
because it will actually it'll hit this
statue and it'll cause a chain reaction
that'll hit more
all right so that was a decent cascade
too we got a couple hits out of that
look over the board and see if there's
any
direct matches where that you can hit
statues and when there's not
we're down to 10 moves so we really need
to create
action as quickly as possible at this
point
i'm going to match the yellow here it's
going to do a couple different things
it's going to drop things down
it's going to set up where we can
explode this blue
and it's also going to bring the
the red down when we do that so i'll
look real quick to make sure there's no
new shockwave matches
and then i'll just explode this blue
pepper
and exploding the blue pepper isn't
really important there what i was hoping
for
and to some extent what i got what i got
was uh more options with the red because
they're all over the place here we can
choose between red or blue but since the
red are going to be
oh slight i mean it's pretty close but
they'll be slightly more effective i
think towards
clearing out the boards i'm going to go
ahead and go with the red
check up top there's no there's no shock
wave match there now so i can take this
one
at the bottom instead
and and now the situation is a little
bit different
no i guess it's still the same i was
going to say it might be good to look at
blues but the reds are just as close to
the statues and we can get an instant
chain reaction with them too so
and that's a nice place for that red one
to fall
okay so now we have
five moves to get one statue but
unfortunately it is probably the most
difficult statue
except for this other one that's in the
same place on the other side to get to
at this point
we're going to there's there's nothing
at the bottom of the board that's very
effective
so at this point we're going to want to
um
create action again
and one thing to note is that
if we make this l
the yellow will match
it won't remove these yellows and we can
we can go back to that later to drop
more peppers down if we need to
green is also near the statue
which uh could come in handy
and there really isn't
a good way to get anything going with
the purple or the blue at the moment so
we're gonna make this match and then
we're gonna
not that one
we're gonna make this match and then see
what happens
all right so now we kind of just want
this uh you know to chill out for a
second
now things are a lot different we don't
want we don't want to start this this
red chain reaction
but starting one with green or purple
will
get us through the level right now so
we have to figure out a way to do that
in the next
four moves
okay so if we match the red here
no i don't like that one all right so if
we match the blue here that'll bring
these two together and we'll have this
one up here so that's the best one
now the bat now the the drawback of that
is
this is going to explode but we have
more grown purples
so the chain reaction is going to um
it's going to get us to where we need to
go
and that dropped one but it didn't drop
enough so that's how you complete the
level
you can see it takes a combination of
all the things we talk about in our
pepper panic tips guide
this level is not as hard as it used to
be but it's still difficult so if you're
stuck here that's not out of the
ordinary
i hope this helps um like i said we did
make this as for a request that someone
had made on our facebook page so we we
encourage you to
let us know what you need and we'll try
to um
develop a new guide or
you know make a video like this
if you found this uh helpful i would be
happy if you would share it
that would help us out and
definitely make sure you like us on
facebook and subscribe to our youtube
channel so you can find out when we make
all this new stuff
we'll have lots of new guides coming
soon so check back regularly
thanks